[Applause]  coming up short again that's it  brooklyn wins it 121 109  and kyrie irving sensational tonight 40  points  made five three-pointers  coming off an all-star start  delivering an all-star performance here  tonight  and you hear the fans in brooklyn  they allowed fans at barclays center the  last couple of games  approaching 1500 fans in the building  tonight  and it's great to see the folks back  keep those vaccinations going everybody  we are  anxious to all be back in the arena soon  together and enjoying this great game  no doubt about it you can see there too  the respect that this group has for  kyrie  he was there for a few years while these  young players were maturing  and a lot of talk about what he was or  was not but you can just tell by those  images that there's a lot of respect for  him in that locker room  last four minutes of the game brooklyn  goes on a 13-3  run to finish off the boston celtics  and the nets improve to 20 a lot of